two years to within the hour of his only
professional loss in the ring to buster
douglas
mike tyson was found guilty of the three
charges against him
tyson is in prison he gets convicted on
a rape charge
so i've got a guy named mitch blood
green who fought tyson
once on the street and once in the ring
and they hate each other
i say to outbreak remember can you get
him in to the facility where tyson is
being kept because i can get him in so
what's he going to say to mike tyson
he's not going to say anything to mike
tyson he's going to hit him with the
best shot
and when tyson gets out who's the fight
that everyone's going to want to see
what made you so good at picking the
winners i just had watched boxing all my
life and i had an aptitude for it i
could tell
who would win manny pacquiao bought a
guy named tim bradley
he beat tim bradley nearly to death and
he lost the decision
manny has tax problems he said it's not
going to hurt me
in terms of my market ability because
everyone's going to see i won this fight
so somebody behind closers bought two of
the judges yeah why is it that
even though fans watch fights and
knowing it was fixed they still keep
wanting to watch these fights
in fights that have any consequence at
all you have to follow the money
if it's going to go to a decision it's
going to favor the guy who's going to
bring money to the business canelo
alvarez
who's fighting for floyd mayweather
mayweather will handle him with ease
they can't let
mayweather lose but they will have him
either win one card
or get a draw on one card and then they
can frame the narrative
he suddenly becomes the best fighter of
all time
[Music]
my guess it is charles farrell he wrote
a book called lowlife
good title a memoir of jazz fight fixing
and the mob
this man is known as one of the greatest
fixers
in the sport of boxing we've had in the
last i don't know 30 40 50 years
40 years and he's gonna tell us maybe
some juicy stories we'll see what's
gonna happen with that being said
charles thank you so much for being a
guest thank you for inviting me so
uh off camera you fully committed to
disclosing all the names
you committed it i just want you to know
that every one of the names except for
the ones that'll get me in trouble
fair enough so what a title why low life
why'd you call it low life
well i it's parenthetical as you know of
course i fully get it
the life itself has its low attributes
and some of what i did might be
considered low life behavior
but it's conjectural and it's a it's a
question of what side
of the fence you're on when you do these
things so i've seen you play i mean
the music instruments you play like it's
insane watching you play i watched the
videos of you
playing boxing you were a kid following
boxing and then people were coming up to
you for recommending
fights and all of a sudden you go into
fixing can you kind of give me the
evolution of how that took place
sure um i've always been interested in
boxing okay
and i've always been involved in music
but i had a mobster uncle
on my my grandfather's sister's
husband was a mobster named joe martini
from new jersey
and you grew up in jersey no i grew up
in boston okay but he would come to
visit
got it and one of the things that i
got from him one of the things that
interested me about him is that he was a
genuinely larger than my figure he was
incredibly gregarious he was generous he
was emotional
and i thought you know he was a guy who
when i was a little kid
would say to me you would give me a math
equation
and if i got it right which i did he
would slip five dollars into my pocket
and he knew how to slip the money into
my pocket which is a skill is
you know and i thought wow that's a kind
of an interesting way
to live he always come with a new car so
i i thought this is a
this is a pretty fascinating life
he fixed up a concession
for one of my grandfather's brothers at
a hotel in boston and it turns out that
the hotel was connected
with um a mobster named maurice levy
who owned bird land and owned roulette
records
and you know and uh what year is this
this would have been i would have known
this would have been the early 60s okay
so i was just a kid got it and
i met a boxing a boston boxer who
took dives periodically very good
fighter named tommy tibbs
who's obscure now but had something like
150 160 pro fights
very very good fighter who had a losing
record but didn't need to have a losing
record
and i followed boxing and tommy said to
the mob guys who used to come to this
concession
charles knows everything there is to
know boxing
you could bet the guys he predicts will
win fights and you guys will win money
so they started having me pick the
winners for them
and that got me involved in gambling on
boxing
because they would give me money to make
predictions for them and then they would
make my bets for me and they looked out
for me for a while
and how did you make your money what was
the model like if you gave them the
right picks did they give you five
percent spiff or did you did you make
something
well i mean or they would get a bet in
for me or they would do both
and you're how old at this time
12. you're you're 12 years old and tommy
is saying that you know
how to pick the winner yes so what was
your system for picking the winners i
just had watched boxing all my life and
i had an aptitude for it i could tell
who would win i just knew boxing you
said something you said there's a
difference between
there's a lot of guys right now that
write good blogs that can figure out who
can win
win a fight and they have the right to
access but they'll get it right 75
percent of the time the keys to go to 90
what made you so good at picking the
fights you know picking the winners
well as i said part of it is just
natural aptitude but also you get
the more you know about you start
talking to people and you start spending
time in the gym
and the gym is really if fights are real
and most fights are real
what percentage is real well i could
give you a percentage i could say
90 of fights are real but it's more
complex than that
because to a great degree
real fights are are so set up
the information is so predetermined
that without fixing the fights you're
still going to get them right
and that's predicated on the way
business works and the way matchmakers
work
so for example if i've got a young kid
and i want him to win his fights and i
don't want to fix his fights
what i can do is i can get information
about the trajectory of other fighters
if a guy is
10 and 8 or 10 and 10 and he works
driving a truck or he works the other
factory
and he's in the gym for a couple of
hours a week
and he doesn't want to get hurt he's got
a wife and kids
he's not going to fight with the same
type of intensity and i will know that
and so even though the fight is isn't
fixed i know this guy
is not going to go more than two or
three rounds because he's
not going to want to get hurt yeah so if
you
factor that in to what percentage of
fights are fixed then it becomes
50. so would you say a lot of the fights
that you were picking were they you know
like you say
in baseball you have major leagues you
have triple a double a single a whatever
and then you got high college you know
bait you know high school were a lot of
these fights local fights
boston fights new york fights or were
there the big fights that you were
picking winners
all debuff all of you about all of them
so how do you how are you able to be uh
good at it with uh
picking fights that maybe the fighter's
not from boston he's from new york maybe
he's from l.a maybe he's from
philadelphia maybe he's from a different
place
and you can't see his training routine
how do you get that intel well in the
beginning i couldn't
okay in the beginning i got it all from
from television from
watching these guys and by analyzing
them so my percentages weren't as good
but they were still good
and then when i got just a little bit
older i spent
lots of time in new york lots of time in
vegas you know i i went to the places
where the fighters were
and i got to know fighters and people
would call me and there was a there's a
kind of network
interesting i went to a 2008 kentucky
derby
okay and i'm there with my wife they
tell us the night before hey if you want
to go talk to the [ __ ] you go see the
horses and talk to the trainers
be up at four o'clock you have access
espn's going to be that route is going
to be i'm like okay i want to go my
wife's like you go i don't need to go
outside okay
i woke up i went there got the card show
it to him i get in
and the trainer of this horse called
eight bells
is talking okay eight bells is a
horse that she looked beautiful like you
know this she could pull it off
and then that was the europe i believe
big brown i don't know if you remember
big brown the horse he was like the main
one you know
everybody wanted to have big brown
everybody was banking on eight brown
and they asked the question they said so
what could you tell us about eight bells
he says she's so competitive
that she's willing to race her heart out
even though it costs her life okay
so i'm standing next to all these guys
kind of like yourself they're looking at
stuff they're looking at the way
horse walks they're looking at the
temperament they're looking at the mood
because that's the date of big kentucky
derby
the final race starts she's in it with
big brown
they're racing she comes out of nowhere
goes all the way down to second place
big brown wins
50 yards later she falls crashes
her leg breaks her leg became the first
time ever to euthanize
a horse on a racetrack of kentucky derby
135 000 people in the audience are
crying it was absolutely intense
experience stayed with me it's just a
very emotional moment but in the morning
i was watching everybody on how they
looked at the horses
when you're going to vegas when you're
going to these different places and
you're looking at these fighters
what are you looking for how do you know
if they're going to be good or bad or
you're looking for
amount of time during the training are
you looking for how
nimble they look if they're eating if
they're listening to their coach if
they're focused
what are some things you're looking for
strange enough the first thing you're
looking for
the most important thing is whether
they're in shape
that's more important than everything
else conditioning conditioning okay
because if things get difficult that's
the first
the first thing that can go you know
that can go bad with you
you look for talent that's a big thing
you look for the way the match-up is
done
so their opponent is a major factor what
does that mean what does that mean
well you what you need to do is analyze
strengths and weaknesses relatively
speaking
so you know so and so does this well and
that matches up very very well with what
his opponent can't do
so there's that that's a very big thing
but you also look at recent
as is true in horse racing you look at
recent activity
and then you get backstory and backstory
is big
what are these guys going through at any
given time
and then you factor all these things
together and then
once you've done that now we're talking
about real fights we're not talking
about things like
what are you talking back stories so
backstories you're looking for what
backstory you're looking for
relationship boyfriend you know
girlfriend drug use drinking use yeah
whether
you know whether they're staying in the
gym whether they're going out whether
they're in trouble
you know all these things um
so you factor those things in uh
and then then
maybe aside from conditioning you know
because i mean that's something that's
sort of insuperable you know if
somebody's in shape
a mediocre fighter who's in great shape
will often beat a really good fighter
who hasn't taken things seriously
a mediocre fighter who's in great shape
will beat a great fighter who doesn't
take conditioning seriously
often wow not all the time i get it yeah
that's big
but i mean you'll get uh you know
probably the greatest fighter in the
last
50 years or so was roberto duran
who in his career stopped training on
and got beaten by people who wouldn't
have been a sparring partner you
shouldn't have lost to those guys
well you know i don't i don't use the
term bombs for fighters but i but
maybe mickey from rocky would call them
bombs yeah he would have
yeah yeah i have to but yes so there's
that but there's the other thing and
this is very very important
in fights that have any consequence at
all
as is true almost anything with
consequence you have to follow the money
who's supposed to win now again we're
not talking about fixed fights
but we're talking about fights where for
example
if it's going to go to a decision
um it's going to favor the guy who's
going to bring money to the business
i'll give you an example of this
a number of you know a number of years
ago canelo alvarez who right now
is probably the top money the crop right
now yeah he
was fighting floyd mayweather who was
the top money maker in the business
before the fight occurred i told people
bet that the fight is going to be a
split decision or a majority decision
i said mayweather will handle him with
ease he'll win nine rounds 10 rounds
he'll never you know he'll never be
troubled by him at all
but this young kid who at the time was
23 or so
is the future of the business he's got a
demographic unlike anything
anyone has seen in years so he's going
to lose
and they can't let mayweather lose
either because mayweather right now
you know is is in the process of being
the biggest moneymaker the
boxing has seen but they need to protect
alvarez so what they will do is that
they will have him
either win one card or get a draw on one
card
and then they can frame the narrative so
the narrative says
well he's just a green kid he's just
learning and he only lost
it turns on a majority decision to the
best fighter in the world and then
they'll
reconfigure that so it's not just the
best fighter in the world
he suddenly becomes the best fighter of
all time
you know so his in other words how
connected are
the the promoters to the media
to the commentators to the writers to
the ref how connected are
like who's not on the same team and who
holds who accountable
i don't know if you know what i'm saying
i know exactly what you're saying in a
sense everybody's on the same team
because
why would they be though well because if
for example here's a fight where it's
important i'll just
go back to this example where it's very
important that canelo's
um save space so he needs to get a
you know he can't win he can't get a
draw um
for a number of reasons but he needs to
lose in a way
that opens the door for a next fight or
something else that you know that this
is a learning experience well
if judges if referees don't follow
the narrative they don't get assignments
it's very simple you want those jobs
if you're not doing what the yeah and
murder doesn't have to ask
because it's also unspoken it's a code
okay so it's not like
you know some of these media companies
on the left and the right they get
criticized for
you ever seen those videos where they
show where 75 different channels they're
all
they're all using the same rhetoric the
same line i don't know if you've seen
that or not and they'll show
you know coronaviruses and the same
exact big words they use and it's like
two sentences
that i'll use people say they should
have had a conference somebody at the
top
sent an email to everybody saying use
these two sentences and they'll use it
they look like robots right right
in this situation you're not saying
there's not a call there's not a meeting
there's not a memorandum there's not any
unspoken rule that i'm telling cam hey
can you whisper
whisper to charles that hey he needs to
lose or she needs to lose or he needs to
is that's not taking place in the box it
doesn't have to take place
it's unspoken they know they all know it
okay so when did you
go and flip from just being somebody
that could read the fighters and pick
them well
when did you flip and saying maybe how
to think about you know fixing these
fights and get involved in that how did
that transition take place
when i started spending my own money
okay because
no matter what happens to your fighter
you're spending your money
and obviously it's to your advantage
well i was going to say it's to your
advantage that your
fighter win and that's true most of the
time it's not true all of the time
but it's true most of the time and well
i'll
we can get to that why why it's not
always true um
but you i realized that first
i was wasting time you know
by even you know i was picking i was
picking correctly almost all the time
because i know the business and i know
fighting but
especially with heavy weights things can
happen guys bang their heads
they you know um they get hit to the
body with a shot that you know
there are contingency things that you
can't predict
and i thought this is crazy if this
other guy's going to lose anyway
why should he have to battle my guy for
seven or eight rounds and really get
kicked around
when i can say to him you don't have to
do this
you're gonna lose anyway i guarantee
you're gonna lose anyway but you're
gonna get hurt
but we can go home early fourth round
third round fifth round yeah whatever
you work out and you can work out
you know there can be incredible
specific
specificity at times but but who
introduced you to this like
when when you know a lot of times you
you see somebody learns
a skill or something but they the time
they go and they learn they come out
they worked on their boss they
learn they duplicate they go do it how
did you learn this i learned it for a
couple of different ways i learned it
from being in the gyms
that was part of it and talking to
fighters
but tommy tibbs the guy who
got me into this to begin with fought a
really really great fighter named willie
pep one of the greatest fighters who
ever lived
and he beat willy pep
and i couldn't for the life of me figure
out how that was tommy b
willie yes and he shouldn't have no not
in any right not it
and i said how did you how did you be
willie
and he said oh i didn't beat willy he
said billy
will he beat willy he said we just took
the odds
i thought wait a minute right you're
this is about making money
it's not about pride it's not about
honor i mean
those things exist i'm not gonna i'm not
trying to demean them
but primarily we're talking about money
and if you can if willy pep is taking a
nothing fight like this
for example and let's say this is in the
late
or maybe the early 1960s
and he's making 1500 for this fight it's
nothing
if if he loses a decision that's
predetermined
and he bets on the other guy or the bet
is placed on the other guy at ten to one
he's making ten thousand dollars
and that's a much much smarter you know
he's an older guy at this point he
doesn't have a career
to go he's not gonna be a world champion
ever again and a lot of
ex-world champions and i know a lot of
ex-world champions who do this
you know it it's it's much smarter and
anyway that's how i started to learn
about it and then
believe it or not there was an ethical
consideration and i'm not going to
try to make myself out to be an angel or
you know an altruist
but i'm a human being and i i started to
see
what happens to these guys and
i thought you know if they don't have to
i mean they're all going to get
damaged it's just going to happen
they're going to wind up neurologically
damaged
you can say that about virtually
everyone and the ones that you can't say
it about
are you know other lottery winners it's
like you know mayweather's a
lottery winner probably probably because
we don't know yet because you don't know
yet
right um and i thought
if if i don't have to be part of this if
there's a way
you know i can exclude myself from this
i'm gonna do it um because i think
morally
it's the right thing to do the right
thing to do is to fix fights so you
saved them four rounds of getting beat
up so in your own mind you felt
comfortable doing what you were doing i
felt very
i wish i'd done more of it i wish i'd
learned about it earlier
i'll tell you why because you're not
talking about four rounds you're talking
about
40 fights at six you know 160 rounds
yeah and and gym work and and
you know a lot of these guys are
sparring partners for champions
and some would say that's pretty crazy
to be thinking that a lot of people will
say it's wrong yeah
and i well you're comfortable with that
that's your position it's absolutely my
position
as it was 30 years ago i'm more adamant
about it now than i was 30 years so you
wish you would have done more you just
said that
you wish i wish i'd done it the entire
time okay so what was your business
model so meaning
uh the system is the system here we've
got
35's coming up let me see this one okay
this one okay boom
these are the four fights i'm going to
pick to fix then after that i'm going to
contact the manager or i'm going to
contact the trainer
walk me through your system i can't do
that because i'll tell why i can't do it
because with variation everything's a
little bit different and it depends on
what the circumstances are
of the people i'm talking to what their
conditions are
what's at stake um okay i'll give you an
example
i'll use names this time at one point i
had a fighter who was a talentless
fighter and i
was horrible i had been
an olympic finalist and you know boxing
is a
an intensely racist business now the
world is an intensely racist
place and he was a white heavyweight
okay so white heavyweight
you know it's the moby dick of boxing
that's that's where the
you know that's the biggest potential
money in the world a white heavyweight
white heavyweight
why why is that because we're a racist
culture
you know that's why a guy like jerry
cooney who was never a heavyweight
champion
who i like personally got purse parody
when he fought larry holmes who was the
heavyweight champion in the world and
one of the
you know inarguably one of the greatest
heavyweights who ever lived
but because people wanted jerry cooney
to be the heavyweight champion so much
there was so much money on the line he
could demand an equal
you know pay day and go and get it
you know completely unproven commodity
anyway
i'm listening to you i've got this white
heavyweight
who i i've i'm moving through the ranks
and i'm keeping them undefeated
and i get suckered i get completely
outplayed
in atlantic city by
bob arum's east coast matchmaker who's a
guy named ron katz
now i've got my unbeaten guy and i've
got floyd patterson training him
because it's a good publicity move you
know
because floyd patterson was a beloved
heavyweight champion and the idea is he
wouldn't be associated with someone who
couldn't fight or someone who
was you know he he would be involved
only with people who were beyond moral
reproach
so i'm buying a lot of good will for
this talentless heavyweight
guy named martin foster
and he's coming in with against a guy
from canada also unbeaten
and i assume that top rank is looking
out for me
but i get played and my guy gets knocked
out
in the first round by a guy named tom
glespie
and that kills off
you know a year of money a year of
business a year of building him up
a year of making deals and you know it's
it's all done
okay so he still got a good record
and a little bit later riddick beau who
was a wonderful fighter
heavyweight champion he's making a
comeback
and i get along well with his his
manager rock newman we get along well
i send sparring partners to him and
at one point they need to put him back
on hbo bow back on hbo and i've got this
guy who at this point is 11-1
and i say to my guy look
there's no way in the world you can beat
riddick beau
it can't happen and he says well
you know i'd like to try and i said no
you would not like to try
you got a wife you got two kids on your
best day
the best that's going to happen to you
is you're going to be beaten to a pulp
by ridicule that's the best that's going
to happen
you're telling them this yeah that's
what's going to happen to you
or you can get knocked out in the first
round
now this is my guy but the business
decision
is for him to get knocked out in the
first round and
he said okay i'll do that now the fight
didn't happen
so there's no great ending to this story
um
because bo wound up doing bigger things
and
he didn't need to tune up but there are
times when it's to your advantage for
your fighter to lose
so in that moment if you do if he does
lose in first round what is a payday for
someone like you
well what do you make what does he make
there are two paydays
or at least two days okay so that's hbo
so it's it's a
uh it knows maybe sixty thousand dollars
okay not much
you know this is 90s this is this is 90s
yeah so
you know he gets 40 i get 20. so it's
not a big payday
you're one or two or split yeah wow
which is what's pretty hefty okay
that's what the law allows and then a
lot of people take 50 but you're not
supposed to do one or two so one third
goes to who would you be considered
you're who
i'm his manager you're his manager you
get a third he gets two thirds correct
hollywood is a lot lower than that so
boxing traditionally is a third time my
agent doesn't get there believe me it
doesn't get 33 in the 30
but that's not where the money is
okay so the third two third forty twenty
he gets forty you get twenty
where's the real money the real money is
betting
that my fighter gets knocked out in the
first round how much is that
it's well it's at that point that would
have been about eight to one
so you put 40k put three you took the
whole thing 60 you put in it
i put 60 in it so you'd make 480. uh
what is it yeah it's 480.
so how do you do it to not be under your
name anybody can
place those bets in vegas so you would
tell somebody else to go place a bet for
you
well it'd be a number of people
because you couldn't be one person doing
it because you get too much attention
way too much attention what are you
typically looking at the max is it 5k
like you know 16 people do five a piece
uh
so no for something like that you would
use fewer
you'd use you could probably get away
with six people
six people do around 13 of them and you
and you're generous
kind of you know you you give them
something you give them a lot
how do you know those guys don't flip on
you
well you got it's got to be people you
trust but also
how are they going to flip on me what
are they going to do well what if they
tell the world that here's what you did
so they kind of have leverage on you as
well why would they do that
what keep the entire money well they
could do that once i suppose
they won't get any more if they do that
right and of course if that becomes
something that people know about them
no at this time are you backed up by a
mob family that's protecting you or no
you're not protected by anybody
unfortunately i was never protected by
mob family
unless i was you know uh fixing fights
for their fighters
so let me go back to a question i asked
you a question i said so what is a
system you look at the 30 fights you
take three okay these guys this is the
three i'm going to pick and i'm from do
you contact the manager
you said i can't tell you why can't you
tell me because it's contingent on
it's it's not that i'm keeping a secret
from you it's because it's contingent on
a variety of conditions not i can't tell
you it's my secret i just can't tell you
i can't do it because sure enough yeah i
just thought maybe
because to me everything is systematic
there is a system to the madness like
even if you look at oceans 11 ocean's 12
right if you look at the movie i'm sure
you've seen both of them
you've probably seen ocean's 11. i saw
the first ocean okay so if you see first
oceans you're saying the first time
you're not a kid so you have to you have
to think about who you need you need a
tough guy you need an entertainer you
need a distractor you need somebody that
knows how to deal with
safes or locks you know somebody that's
got to be pretty you know someone that
knows the contacts you know someone
that's a driver
so there's a system to the madness that
part of it yes you're saying in your
world there is no system to the madness
well i
no i if if you use those criteria yeah
that all exists that continues to exist
in your world oh yes can you can you
tell us what that system would be like
what would it look like what are some
things you need to fix a fight all right
for one thing
there are a number of ways to do it so
i'll give you a bunch of them
the easiest way is that you've got one
guy who's going to get knocked out
by far that's the easiest and that's
what you're looking for
you know because again it doesn't take
into account
extraneous factors you're talking about
two guys
and they control actually i was gonna
say two guys but that's not even true
one guy controls the entire play
so that's the easiest way to do it
the second thing is that you've got the
ref
if you've got the ref he can give
he can do things that engineers the the
nature of the fight
if your guy is getting hurt and isn't
supposed to be he can call breaks he can
call fouls
he can stop the fight there are a lot of
things they can do
the other thing is that on any fight
it's going to go the distance you only
need two judges
um judges make how much money a couple
hundred grand a year
judges don't make anything close to that
okay so you can buy judges no
well here's the funny thing not only can
you buy judges
this isn't true of all judges but a lot
of judges are in it
because they like being in it lifestyle
yeah connections yes were you with
tonight
mike ty i was in a blue ring with mike
tyson what's an average judge make are
they making money or no
no they make that you can't make a
living at it okay or you can't make much
of a living at it you know it depends
i mean there are there are guys who who
referee
a major fight i just typed in right now
average boxing judge's salary said a
hundred thousand
to two hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year annually and that's a
legitimate that's a star referee that's
a star referee yeah okay
yeah so regularly
so these guys want to be in the light
they're like oh my gosh look who is hey
you know the
you know starting player for chicago
bulls comes and shakes my hand you know
hollywood star is here
it's kind of one of those and that's and
that's what you play up got it so you
become friendly with these guys so you
got number one
is the guy's gonna get knocked out no
matter what whether it's the ninth round
the fourth round the second round you're
getting knocked out why don't we
convince you to knock out
in a first round number two is a referee
number three is a judge all you need is
two of the judges
what else do we have um other than that
that's that's really all you need got it
so who talks to who like
how do you talk to the judge or how do
you talk to the referee what is the
conversation sound like
when you're speaking to these guys well
again it depends on how well you know
them how close you are to them and
whether you've done business with them
before
there are guys you can say you've got to
give my guide the decision
straight up you can do that you can also
say to people
look i'm i'm trying to build so and so
if you can look out
for him a little bit i'll appreciate it
and you know it's four favors down the
line
and again you have to be good you have
to be as good as your word
it's very important that if you say
you're going to do something for
somebody
they have to know that you're really
going to do it
got it so my mind creative mind went
somewhere
okay business model like this i see fear
hey
joe if you don't do this dot dot okay
fear
threat number two is selfish okay
which has to do with money and number
three to me is favor
right favor okay so you got favor hey
look out for this guy it's bringing up
let's
take look out for him he could me okay
great i'ma look don't worry about it i
got you charles i'm gonna do this great
right the other one is money the other
one is fear which of those three tactics
the
most effective money
okay you know no i didn't deal in fear
uh
because you didn't have backup that's
why i was wondering if you had anything
i'm not i'm not a tough guy
you know now there were times
when i when i was working when i was
fighting
making fights for mob guys that the fear
was inherent
and it's implied you know well you never
brought it up they just knew
i would say he's with him
you know he's with whatever i mean if i
was bringing a you know a russian
fighter
down south well the inference someone
would make is why is a russian fighter
fighting in you know the carolinas well
look at who's going to the ring with
i got it so yeah yeah and you always you
know
and you're not stupid and people love to
be told
that they're not stupid and they love
being in on stuff
god so johnny you're not stupid that
guy's right there just so you know
his muscle is right there i don't even
say that i said look at him
look at him look who's with and see god
it doesn't matter who he's with now let
me ask you how how dangerous is the life
for a referee or a judge
yeah you're like you know you know how
in soccer remember that one
colombian soccer player accidentally
kicks the ball into his own goal
you know what happened to the guy i
killed the guy i don't know if you know
this sir they killed the guy
you know these stories happen
is it a dangerous life to be a referee
or a judge are they pretty protected
do you know what i'm saying yeah no i
would say it's not particularly
dangerous okay so they're protected so
it's not like they're working
protected it's that mistakes happen
you know and it's not that's nothing
that people get killed for
the other thing is that again you have
to understand the way the business moves
a couple of mistakes in key places and
those
you know those contracts dry up charles
at your peak what kind of money were you
making
oh not a lot not a lot idea
[Music]
i'm trying to think how much of this i
can say best fight you're like what's
your best fight best one you had where
you said i made
a [ __ ] load of money on this one fight
uh just just under a hundred thousand
just under a hundred thousand that's
your purse that's mine okay not purse
that's what i made right which you made
off of that yeah okay
and you know but i lost a lot more than
the biggest loss i ever did what's your
biggest loss
i lost 100 400 and 420 or 430 thousand
dollars that happened
it's an amazing story i'm not sure if i
got suckered
or if i made a legitimate mistake
because the person who brought me
that bet was my best friend in boxing
and a guy
who actually saved my life so i hate to
think
that i got taken but the deal was this
there was a middleweight championship
vacant middleweight title
between a guy named reggie johnson and
a guy named stevie collins irish stevie
collins who were very very
well matched guys and if the fight were
real which it turned out to be
uh it would go neither one had ever been
knocked out and even
neither one ever did get knocked out in
their career so
it would be a close fight and would go
to a decision
okay my friend al braverman who was don
king's director of boxing and really my
closest friend in boxing
said i've got something that just came
over the transom
you might be interested in it what would
you do
if i told you that you get three to one
on stevie collins over reggie johnson
and i said
what what what do i know you know what
what don't i know about this fight he
said that's the right question
but as far as i know nothing your friend
is telling you this he's telling me this
because he saved your life mm-hmm
from the mob interestingly enough he
saved your life from the model he did so
the mob was after you and he protected
you
yeah not for this fight but for
something completely different i'm
curious to know what it is please
continue
to tell you that although that one we
won't give names but because they're all
still around
um but it should have been an even money
bet
and i thought well you know he said but
the only thing
it's got to be a big bet okay
so i got together all the money i had
without having to borrow which at that
point it was either 4 30 or 4 20 and i
don't remember which
and i had to fly in a private plane
under the radar
down to santa domingo to get the bet
made
and fight went the distance it was very
very close
and and the the other reason i bet
stevie collins is politically it was by
far
the more the you know the better
business uh
moved because collins had big business
with super middleweights
in europe there were plethora of big
money fights for him to
to be to be made for him so i thought of
course he's going to win
you know as as braverman said nobody
gives a [ __ ] about either of these
fighters i said well in europe they
you know collins they do but nobody
gives a [ __ ]
about reggie johnson so he loses
anyway reggie johnson wins a majority
decision
and i'm down in santa domingo with my
bodyguard
and cash and whoever i bet against who i
never met
some gangster had his two bodyguards
and they had their cash so i handed over
the cash and that was it and i thought
well
you know i made the wrong bet it happens
you were supposed to make what 1.29
it was one two five i think or something
like that you're a good mathematician
yeah i mean enough so that i was going
to get out yeah and i was going to
you were going to get out like i'm done
with it i'm done i've got i've got money
that nobody knows about i'm going to
live in the caribbean
quietly yeah yeah right i don't need
this i mean i'm
uh i already owned real estate down
there but i was going to buy how many
times have you have you replayed that
moment in your life
well here's the thing at first quite a
bit but
you know it's done there's nothing you
can do about it but here's what i
started replaying
i thought if
the guy who i lost the bet to could find
10 people to make this bet with
and by the the judges one you know
again two judges 10 people
you know that's that's 4 million
300 000 or 4 million 2. you know for
nothing for no i mean you have to have
the cash
to put up but that's not so hard to do
and he walks away and i thought did my
best friend
get a cut on it gotta cut on it are you
still good friends with the guy he died
he's
he was he was an elderly guy when i knew
him he
he died in a completely enough how did
he save your life how did he save your
life
um i was
making fights for a kid who was in the
whose father was in the mob and they had
spent money on this white heavyweight i
won't say his name
he was terrible he was absolutely
horrible
and um
i had been doing business down south
with a veteran matchmaker
and who who knew his business guy who
really understood
what he was doing so this kid was going
to turn pro
this mob kid and we brought him to a
safe environ
where under the radar you know nobody
because we wanted a first round knockout
and i was given money to give to this
matchmaker
which i did and i said okay so it's one
round
it's one round and he said um
yeah no problem at all we're at the
fights
and i don't i patrick to this day i
don't know how
this happened but just before the fight
i had this intuition
where i went into the loser's dressing
room the loser was clearly a kid who
couldn't fight
i mean i could see that right away and i
was talking to his his
handlers manager i don't know who the
guy was
and i said so he knows what to do
and he said what do you mean he says you
mean
does he know how to fight i said no i
can tell you he doesn't know how to
fight
but you know what's going to happen
right and he goes
i said how much did you get paid for
this fight he goes
you know we get paid 80 bucks a round
four round fight
and i said okay so i go back
into the the audience because the new
york guys are all there
and i said look there's a little there's
a little issue here um
and i still remember the kid's father
gets up he puts his arm around me and he
makes sure that i see
he's got a gun and he says well you're
going to handle it
and i said yeah i'm going to handle it
and he says okay
how bad language can i use here whatever
you want yeah it's fine
he said if we don't get what we want
we're going to kill you we'll kill that
[ __ ]
who stole our money and we're going to
kill the fighter
and everybody else we can think of and
these are serious guys
he whispers this to you yeah and he's a
boss at the time he's not a boss but
he's
you know connected he's con yeah he's
connected and he's
and he's the you know he's got the
fighter so he and he's the son of a son
of somebody somebody powerful in the
mind
and they've already they're already
spending a lot of money on this kid's
career and this kid cannot fight at all
not not even a little bit and he's
petrified because this is his first pro
fight
so i go back to the dressing room and
i said kid you're going to lose this
fight you're going to get knocked out in
the first round
and he says i can't do it.
he's a southern kid he's i can't do it
because
my parents are in the audience my
sisters and brothers and i said
we're going to all be dead in the next
10 minutes
and it gets weirder he says he's from
new york
he's going to kill me anyway i said no
no he didn't understand
he's in his dressing room throwing up
right now
if you even look at him he's going to
faint i know you can't fight
but he doesn't know that so
you're going to lose and then the
matchmaker comes in
and i said to the matchmaker what did
you do he goes this kid can't fight at
all
i said that's not what you got paid to
do you got paid to fix the fight
fix the fight no but it's going to be a
one-round fight he can't fight
i said you took his money and
i said give me all the money you've got
everything you've got he goes well
some of this is my money i don't want
your money anymore
it's this kid's money and then i said
and i said to the kid i'm not gonna tell
you his name either
but i had a a brainstorm i said look you
don't have to fight under your own name
nobody cares
makeup and i'm just gonna say like his
name is
you know billy alexander which is not i
said make up a name he goes and he's
crying at this point
he's actually crying he goes uh bobby
alexander and i said no no billy see
bobby alexander sounds quite a bit like
billy alexander
you know and he'd say well bobby
alexander you know
it's okay we'll take care of it and i
said to the
matchmaker
you got to give this kid under his own
name four wins
so he starts his pro career at 4-0 this
this is you know
so he's okay we'll do that and i take
the kid
out into the parking lot and there are
still
people straggling in because this is you
know early this is one of the first this
is in fact the opener
of the fight i said put your hands up
now i'm not a fighter and you know i was
a lot younger then but i wasn't a
fighter then either
i hit the kid in the mouth as hard as i
can
and then i hit him in the stomach as
hard as i can and then i hit him in the
mouth as hard as i can and he starts
he gets bloody lip and i say to the kid
the guy whose
can the towel comes in right then that's
what happens and i said don't you throw
a punch back
don't you dare throw a punch back this
is how it is and i said
you throw the towel in high right out to
the middle ring and you yell
something as you throw it in
which he did the fight lasted 17 seconds
and it looked
sensational and the mob guys
they love me again everything is good
and i think
okay everybody got what they wanted
that's good business
and then they say we need to talk to
this matchmaker
and i said you don't need to talk to
you got exactly what you wanted he's
scared to death he didn't make a dime
he lost his own money it's done
just think business just you're telling
this to the mob
mobster yeah this is business you know
if something had happened it would be
all
you know i could see the the the wisdom
of doing something about it but there's
nothing to be done
they said go get them so
we drive over to the restaurant where
this guy
you know is eating with the matchmaker
matchmaker is a rich kid
whose wife bankrolls these things and
they're you know they're
they're spending time with their society
friends you know
rubbing elbows with the fighters and
this matchmaker sitting and eating with
them and i said come on over here
and he gestures i'm eating
right now and i almost never get mad at
anybody
i thought okay i go to the matchmaker
and i said to the promoter and i said we
need to borrow
this guy for a little while and this is
one of those guys you've met them we all
met them a promoter
who has a sense of when to cut to cut
loose
the weak you know the weak part of the
herd he knows that something's going on
he was going to
take him so we bring him out and the mob
guys to get into the van
and i think oh jesus christ
and so he gets into the van and i get
into the van
i'm thinking this is so stupid but you
know i'm also thinking
this is it and they make this guy
direct them because he's a local out of
town
so they're driving we're we're in the
van in the back seat and we're
surrounded
by these mobsters and one of them i
one of them i know what he does for a
living and i won't say what it is but
you can guess what it is
and they're talking about the
matchmakers if he's not there which is
maybe the scariest thing
of all because he's pleading you know he
said i know i made a mistake i'll never
do it again it was it was stupid i
you know i the guy i got can't fight
it's nothing you know
and they're talking about him in the
third person you know what do you do
with a piece of [ __ ] like this you can't
reason with them
i think no no this guy's over with well
that's what
so we drive out to the middle of country
they open the van they say to the guy
step out and walk 10 feet to take 10
steps
and he's stumbling and i think all right
well
you know it takes 10 steps
and they say okay get back in the van.
and they nothing happens they drop them
off and i said okay that was great you
know
you scared them to death you scared me
to death
and they said no this isn't over with
and it turns out it wasn't over with
so something happened
he died here they killed him i'm not
going to say what happened but i cuz i
can't say that but
he's not around anymore physically
spiritually but not physical i don't
even know if he's around spiritually and
then
somebody else associated with the same
did that happen fairly quickly or no not
as quickly as you would imagine
but but fairly quickly yeah and then
somebody else had a mishap too that i
can't talk about
the other person might have missed that
but not the fighter not the fighter
fighter okay
fighter as far as i know is still around
and the guy that that brought his
fighter the guy that uh
the the son of a gangster is the s does
this
is the gangster no longer around but the
sun is still around today
i think they're both still around oh
you're saying they're both stuff
yeah i think so i mean they're not have
i interviewed them
no okay no but that that that takes a
lot of names out
it takes takes yeah no you haven't and
and you would you know who i've
interviewed
i know some of the people you've entered
yeah no no it wouldn't be no i
one of them in particular would come to
mind but no okay no
but but what's interesting is that they
decided they were gonna kill me
uh partially because they thought i
would give them up
which is something i wouldn't do and al
braverman fixed it for me
the guy who the 420 430 that could have
been a 1.25 yeah i was living in the
mountains of puerto rico
and they were looking for me and i was
getting really desperate i mean i was
really getting desperate because
the guy who was going to be dispatched
like me
and he called me before and he said you
better straighten this out
and i said they're sending you and he
said i think they're sending me
so you better handle it they sent him
it's over it's over yeah so i mean it'd
be hard to find me
but you know i don't necessarily want to
i in those days i live in a place called
las marias puerto rico
it's in the mountains you know it's the
middle of nowhere and i liked it there
but
it's not where i wanted to spend the
rest of my life
anyway braverman had us all meet
in new york and i came in from from las
marias to new york and we had a
in-person meeting and he said uh we can
sign your kid with don king
we can't sign your kid with dunking he
said we can sign your kid with don king
but charles is with us
and he's not talking to anybody and this
is the end of it
if if anything happens to him
your kid will not be welcome anywhere
and if he does get a fight
you're going to wish he didn't and al
braves and one of those guys who's just
completely fearless you know just a
and so that was it and of course i've
never mentioned their names
let me ask you how much till today is
that still happening
how much is fixing still happening today
in boxing it's about the same as ever
it's about the same as ever yeah
yeah five exactly so so let me ask you
so you know
every time there's a fight and you're
sitting there you're like there's no way
in the world what just happened here
there's no way that guy should've won
are you kidding me
in every possible way the other guy
wants right i don't know how this makes
any sense
right and then people will go on twitter
facebook youtube and say this
was fakes i'll never watch another
boxing fight right the next big fight
comes you're watching it on pay-per-view
right
why is that why is it why is it that
even though fans watch fights and
knowing it was fixed they still keep
wanting to watch these fights
because well for one thing most of the
fights you're talking about go to a
decision right that's a bad decision
it's a decision yeah so they see a real
fight
i'll give you an example now i i don't
know personally that this is fixed but i
would bet my life that it was fixed
do you remember a number of years ago um
manny pacquiao
bought a guy named tim bradley yes okay
he beat tim bradley nearly to death
and he lost the decision now at this
point
pacquiao is maybe the biggest money
maker in boxing
or you know maybe floyd may you know but
he's certainly the most influential guy
in boxing he's going to be the president
of the philippines and you know he's a
major
short icon yeah he wins
nine rounds ten rounds and he loses
to bradley now a couple of times i'm
watching this fight and i see
that that manny can knock him out and he
doesn't do it
get out of here again manny has
this is what people tell me tax problems
and he's got gambling problems and he
has hangers on
and the odds again are about eight to
one
i think what happened is he said it's
not gonna hurt me
in terms of my marketability because
everyone's gonna see i won this fight
so that won't do me any harm and
whatever you can make make now i don't
know
i you know 8-1 you put 2 million to make
16 million whatever you can make yeah
whatever you can put down in china you
can put down
you know a ton of money in the you know
at that point
because china you can put down well at
one point china wanted
was you know uh manny was aaron's
fighter at the time and aaron
was looking to do big business in china
and wound up doing some promoting there
and my guess again it's just in a kind
of
experience speculation that's all it is
because that's where the money came from
and i think everybody made a ton of
money
and to me that's a fixed fight
to you that's a fixed fine sure that to
me is also a fixed bite so
so somebody behind closers bought two of
the judges yeah
that's what you're thinking did it in a
way that didn't harm do you have any
insider a clue the insider
feedback that gives you even more
validation that this happened or no
on this fight i'm not even sure if i
remember what happened but i'll tell you
there's a kind of rule of thumb that you
can follow
if a fight's going to be fixed where
within
through the judges you often see
the the kind of standard names who show
up all the time and then a ringer comes
in from out of town who's no one's ever
heard of
don king used to do this all the time he
said who who is this person
god that's a bot judge
uh that happened in uh one of uh
lennox lewis's fights against evander
holyfield where
i forget the woman's name but you know
this completely improbable score and
she showed up for the one fight and no
one had heard of her before and no one
has heard of her since
and you know so let me let me ask you
this other question so let's just say
if i'm vegas i'm the other side
right well if you're vegas what you're
trying well
yeah i mean what i'm saying is but if
i'm vegas on the other side the eight to
one is to me as well as much as it is
eight
one on the street money right okay
because i'm dictating the
the numbers so if i'm vegas yeah am i
not
hiring the highly intellectual
investigators like you and i'm getting
somebody like you
you're like an i.t guy you're not a
fighter you're brains you're you're a
guy that's sitting you can read all that
i would give a guy like you quarter
million dollars saying hey can you read
the [ __ ] and to see if anything is
going on
and i got 20 of you guys on a payroll
but nothing but nothing's going on in a
fight like that
the odds are exactly what they should be
think about it the other
yeah but but okay so for example give me
an idea in the insurance industry okay
i've been insurance industry now 20
years right i've dealt with aig
trans america you name them i've dealt
with them right okay so
one of my client dies okay got it i got
a quarter million
insurance policy on them getting ready
to deliver the quarter million dollar
insurance policy
okay the investigators come and they do
their audit if it's within two years
in contestability clause phase that they
have they'll go through it right
and they'll go back and they say wait a
minute this guy tested the
non-smoker but the last 17 physicals
that we looked at and any kind of thing
he's tested for
everybody said he's a smoker why did he
come out in a non-smoker they'll go
deeper and that's oh his brother pete
for him instead of him
paying for we're not giving a quarter
million dollars because they spent
they have the brains guys they hire to
go do the investigation that's what
happens on an insurance case
sure all the time why isn't vegas hiring
a full-on team of 40
you know forensics guys that can go out
there and audit to see how
dirty it was and on the inside let's
figure this because if you don't yeah
this person can never have a job here
ever again you will never work with us
ever again you think this is fun you
think you
you will never be a referee here ever
again you will never be a judge here
never again
because i can control that right why
wouldn't vegas hire a team of forensics
to catch
good question for one thing
judging is is subjective now it's true
everyone's going to look at and say
something's wrong this
but the other thing is you're talking
about one fight
where they get they get hit they get
hurt
but you're doing business with them all
the time you know
there's you know you every once in a
while you're going to take one on the
chin
and you do that you know i mean i'll
give i'll give you another example
okay i
i was in the room i brought vin
vecchioni i
paid for him i flew to new york with him
to talk to al braverman
when he fought mike tyson okay
so at that point this is the biggest
money event in sports history it's not
anymore but it was at the time
so we'll go there tyson was supposed to
fight somebody else he was supposed to
fight
uh he's supposed to win the title on his
first fight back you're supposed to
fight oliver mccall
but all oliver call is a was considered
too much of a loose cannon
and he would have knocked mike house i
you know mike we can talk about this in
your show by the way
uh you know so they they come up with
this
kid peter mcneely who's got a totally
fabricated record
um meaning what you know he's fighting
guys who can't fight he's gonna you know
he has a record but it's not like he's
studying everyone and
and uh you know and he's fighting guys
who just can't fight even a little bit
and in friendly environs too so
um but
the so the fight gets made it's the
biggest money fight in history the
biggest sporting event in history at the
time
the day before the fight i get a call
from somebody i know i'm still i'm in
puerto rico again
and he said somebody just made a
million-dollar bet
that the fight wouldn't go a full 90
seconds somebody
thought you might be interested in that
now i couldn't do anything about it
i was too far away i couldn't get a bet
down
at the 89 second mark my friend vin
vaccioni steps into the ring
forcing a stop to the fight
now somebody made that 90-second bet and
i know who did
and you know it takes nerves of steel to
to wait
till you know because you have to find
some plausible reason to do it somehow
and you know you have to hope this is
not a fixed fight in the sense that
neither fighter was told to do anything
it's based on what
vin knew about his fighter's skill level
that he was terribly overmatched the
point is
vegas understands that
something went wrong yeah because the
questions they asked post fight were
like
he was selling himself why he got
knocked out at 89 seconds
if you notice closely my knees buckled
yeah yeah
you know what i'm talking about yeah but
here's the thing
and this is what you were saying he
didn't know because vegas thought he
knew
that the fighter knew if i did not know
peter had no clue no clue
no he was told because again if he had
gone if
a miracle had occurred and he'd won
that would have been even bigger because
again
you've got a white heavyweight who's
knocked out mike tyson in this first
fight back
so you do it again so
there's no lose there it doesn't matter
you know i mean
obviously the thoughts to the one better
than one million dollars whatever the
amount is with the 90
in 90 seconds yeah so but here's the
thing okay so
how feared of a person was that one
million or better
oh uh my guess is not fair at all okay i
think i think what happened is
ben found one person or a couple of
people and cut him in for a big piece
makes sense yeah yeah i mean it wasn't
it wasn't a uh sports book yet
got it it was a private debt okay anyway
please
so you have to assume that people who
are associated with boxing in vegas
look at this and they see something's
not right you don't
step into the ring to stop a kid even
he's going to get knocked out maybe
but this is the biggest event in history
and
what can accrue from it is enormous so
you give him a chance
if he gets knocked out he gets knocked
out but you know nobody knows
what tyson is at this point either you
know he's been in jail for years he's
put on
tons of weight and he took it off you
know in ways that have nothing to do
with getting in shape
you know so he looks great but he's not
in fighting shape
at first they think about holding up the
purse but what happens if you hold up
the purse
the biggest money fighter guy who
brought in about a billion dollars in
revenue for the city
for that for that fight if he's
under you know under suspicion means the
whole game is under suspicion
now do you [ __ ] up the whole game for
this one thing that got you the result
you wanted anyway you don't
so you know
so that's that's how something like that
are there any fighters where you you
went up to him you're like
you were you you said you fixed how many
fights hundreds of fights hundreds of
hundreds of fights yeah
uh and were any one of them you fixed
like title fights were there any
big big fights or no i
fixed i fixed um
champions championship fighters fights
many times i didn't fix championships
big names people would know about yeah
big names people would know about from
80s 90s
from 90s to 2000s early 2000s
heavyweight lightweight all over but but
um
i'm trying to think of how many former
heavyweight champions do you have a
fight
you fixed hypothetically do you have a
you fixed that you were part of that if
the world knew about it that would be
shell-shocked
yes yeah a a few of them
i can't they're they're around and you
know when people
can can we do like one question just one
question you don't have to i can try
i'm going to ask a question i'll do my
best because let our imagination have
something
too much see if we can answer this
the one that we would be shell-shocked
was the fighter latino black or white
the one that you would be shell-shocked
both fighters were black
i mean if you would have said filipino
we figured it out but that's definitely
not going to be the case
i'm going to give you one more hit but
this is where it stops riddle give us a
riddle both
both fighters are black and both
fighters at one time had been the
heavyweight champion of the world
and you haven't mentioned their names
today no okay they're both around
they're both friends of mine
and we've given a lot of clues if i'm a
betting man a person should be able to
figure this out
and these two were in the 90s these were
in the 90s
at this point of the game i mean people
who are watching it they're probably
guessing down there putting their names
there but again you're not going to say
who it is so this
this was a this was a you thing this was
a mop thing this was a collaboration
this was the fix were other big names
involved in the fix or
oh no this is this is something that
that the fighters themselves fixed and
uh
they knew about it yeah my guy calls me
beforehand
and neither one of them talks about it
till today no one knows about it it's
never been written i've never been
talked about never
never never how many people know that
that fight was fixed if you were to say
there's this many people that were on
the inside two of them are no longer
with us
how many are living that were involved
in that fix that would know it
five names three names maybe five
minutes maybe five
maybe five including the fighters
but you guys have kept it to yourself
all these years
yeah yeah no this is the five names if
you guys are good at keeping secrets
like that never
yeah i should hire you you shouldn't
hire me yeah you should come work with
me
we want you on our team i want you
charles yeah
dang that's pretty intense and you're
saying it still happens today now let me
ask you a different question
so uh my opinion my opinion where i'm at
okay so you got boxing
okay uh before i get to my one question
one
basic question i'll ask is there
anything any sport or any game that's
more fixed than boxing
in your opinion or you may not know i
don't follow sports okay so you don't
know horse racing
i'm told by people in horse racing the
horse racing is almost entirely fixed
entirely almost entirely fixed okay so
perfect let's put so all those paintings
our horses have on the wall i should
take them down
let's put the horse's name down that was
99 to one he probably should have won
the whole thing
but uh okay boxing ufc
ufc comes in okay yeah it's controlled
by
a personality boxing doesn't have that
ufc is controlled by a a boss right
they know white is a boss right he's not
a uh
uh a uh you know adam silver personality
he's a david stone could have been a
boss david stone was a ball i don't know
if you all have david strong
i don't know what i know commissioners
right different sports
okay yeah you don't hear a lot of this
stuff with ufc
matter of fact there'll be a ufc fight
where the
judges favor somebody else they know why
it goes and fires them yeah
and he just flat out goes and says
you're flipping fired make the hell out
of you you ever do something like this
again
so to him it seems like he is so
maniacal about making sure fixing
doesn't happen in his sports
do you think fixing also happens in the
ufc world well again i don't i don't
follow him so i don't know but my guess
is
he's you know dana white seems to have
the thing so monopolized
and is making so much money at it yeah
and part of the
it seems to me part of the pitch for
that is that we don't play games no
anybody can lose at any time
you know even even the guys who are
building up they can lose there's no
great shame in losing
if that's true there are probably
good reasons for him not to fix fights
but but i don't know that's an
uninformed opinion like you know like
for example give me an idea if i'm a
fixer
okay if i'm a fixer let's just say uh uh
my name is dana white and i'm trying to
set up for a big fight
conor mcgregor is fighting poetier right
conor's supposed to win
right conor loses right portia knocks
him out like dude
people don't want to watch podium fight
uh you know
uh khabib they want to see conor khabib
right
everybody in the world was pissed off
because that's the big fight so
if it is about fixing you go and tell
podi a drop you know in second round
because
but it didn't happen right that's the
part where the game
keeps the integrity the fight keeps the
integrity um
was there any any time where some big
boxes and you know we can wrap up on
on a couple of these and i'll give you
the final thoughts anything else you
want to share with us
um was there ever a fighter where you're
like you know we tried to get this guy
to fix
was a big name he just wouldn't do it he
has so much pride he wouldn't even do it
whether it was at the end of his career
or not he just wouldn't do it was there
any people anybody like that
again if there were i wouldn't tell you
but
i'm just curious if you know like i'm
not asking for a name was there any
fighter where you're like this guy was a
cover on every ring magazine everywhere
sports list we knew him
but he wouldn't no matter how much you
paid him he wouldn't do there is one guy
um who was
in fights that were fixed that he didn't
know were fixed who
we were interested in getting i was
interested in other people were
interested in getting and
it was no dice uh i can say again
he's a uh was a very very high profile
heavyweight champion
mickey ward vicki ward
no mickey warren as as far as mickey
ward's only been in real fights
as as far as i know no i see mickey like
you know his fight with gotti yeah
seen three or three of them the greatest
fights of all time i mean you can just
sit there and watch that one
god he's down oh my gosh guys
like the fans won that day i mean the
video today's got like 100 million views
you can watch it on repeat over and over
and over again
yeah see it's fights like that you know
how they say in golf
you know here's how golf works you hit
one good ball you're coming back
you're good at one good ball you're
gonna come back and try this again right
and like today sucked and look oh did
you see that drive let's do it again
next week right
right boxing's that you get that one
fight we haven't had it for a while i
mean but i haven't seen a good boxing
fight for a while
but you you look at the mickey fight you
got it vicky ward
made a million dollars in this i think
it was in the second fight and certainly
in the third fight now here's a guy
who works in construction his top payday
is about 40 000 bucks up until then hbo
says we'll give you a million dollars
and of course it was the smartest
million dollars you could find
right i mean you know you're going to
get something for your money
and they did a movie about them it's
actually a very good story i don't know
if you watch it well
i know mickey i know who's the biggest
fighter who's the best fight you've ever
seen yourself you're a fight a fan well
i
favorite fighter at a time that you
didn't fix and screw up like my favorite
when i was a boy i actually saw
sugar ray robinson fight live so
sugary robinson any specific one or just
he was your favorite fighter to watch
period
he was my favorite fighter he's the best
fighter i've ever seen now when i saw
him he was 41 years old he was you know
way past his prime and he
in a fight where the judges got bought
interestingly enough in boston by sam
silverman he lost his title
to a guy named paul pender who's a
boston fighter
the best fighter i've now so i saw i
actually saw robinson live
and he's the best fighter but the
robinson i saw was a 41 year old
robinson so the best fighter i ever saw
in his prime by far was roberto duran
who i saw fight live when he was 20.
at 20. hands of stone monster
you know he fought in madison square
garden i went to the fight he fought a
guy named buena
juertas who was a not a good fighter but
a tough guy
and he knocked him out in the first
round
everybody in madison square garden said
okay
we've we're seeing something important
we're seeing somebody
memorable and it turns out he was you
know
better than better than anyone i've ever
seen
i mean tyson swears by him tyson tyson's
like a big duran fan
you know it's a i went to panama and
when i went to panama he had a
restaurant there he would always dance
with his wife
at the at the restaurant and you just
see a regular guy well people don't
really
regular 25 years prior to that he would
whoop your
ass do it right now because he would
probably do it right now
doesn't look like a boxer though it
doesn't look like a boxer but
it's um any any give you the last chance
here your book
low life low life do i have to
untold stories you have for us to share
any crazy last untold stories you have
for us
just think about it like yeah but your
grandkids let you say they're watching
right now they're sitting there saying
grandpa papa daddy you know you don't
give me one
last story do you think that the tyson
mcnealy thing is okay i'll give you
give me one more i'm greedy i'll give
you i'll give you that one one fight
fight that didn't happen but but it's
worth it okay
tyson is in prison okay so
and tyson can't fight i know ted
everyone knows eisen can't fight he was
he no i'll give you a little backstory
too he's put in prison deliberately
because he's dissipating remember he's
the biggest money fighter in the world
but he's falling apart what year is this
this is
whenever just after he lost to uh to
douglas so
this is like starts in the late 80s so
he gets convicted on a rape charge
king does everything he can to keep him
on
just the opposite just the opposite
he needs to put him on ice he's falling
apart
so he's going to implode what's the best
thing you can do
take him out of circulation and he
becomes the hottest property in the
world
right all it doesn't matter who he
fights when he gets out
but he can't fight anymore that's
important to know
so i've got a guy named mitch blood
green
who fought tyson once on the street and
once in the ring
i say to al braveman and they hate each
other
i say to al braverman how about
mitch green he goes you know he's crazy
i said
i got something for you can you get him
in
to the into the facility where tyson is
being kept he said yeah i can get him in
i said just get him in
just get him in he says why what are you
going to do people are going to want to
know what mitch green has to say to mike
tyson
since there are mortal enemies because i
can get him in he said what's he going
to say to mike heisen i said he's not
going to say anything to mike tyson
what's he going to do he's going to nail
mike tyson
he's going to hit him with the best shot
he can think of
and when tyson gets out who's the fight
that everyone's going to want to see
and you've got a safe opponent and i've
got
i've just made a million dollars
so why didn't it happen
because mitch green says to me how much
he making
i said i don't know you're making a
million dollars
he going to get more than me you know
i'm trying to say
i don't i don't know i said yeah so
knock him out
and then you'll make more than he does
and he says i ain't doing nothing to
promote that guy
and i couldn't get him to do it why
didn't he want to promote that guy he
hates
him just because of that just because
all the money in the world he wouldn't a
million dollars were both
broke a million dollars and i said
tyson can't fight anymore just get
through the first few rounds and he's
i can see it you know he's going to
implode and then you'll be the
heavyweight champ and
my guy she has no business being the
heavyweight champ but you know
things are what they are and tyson i can
see doesn't want to fight
so that's it's kind of a boxing story
that's a that's a boxing story for sure
that's a crazy boxing story
folks if you're watching this uh
low life a memoir of jazz
fight fixing and the mob our friend here
charles
thank you so much for coming on i really
enjoyed it thank you thank you
definitely really enjoyed it we're gonna
put the link below
to order the book